Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see that the
research papers that you see here
in this series are real. Here you see NVIDIA’s
game changing videoconferencing AI. So what does
this do? Why is this so interesting? How does
this transfer a video of us over the internet?
Well, here is a crazy idea. It doesn’t! What?
Transmitting video without transmitting video?
How is that even possible?
Well, now, it is possible!
What they do in this work, is take only the
first image from the video, and they throw away
the entire video afterwards! But before that,
it stores a tiny bit of information from it,
which is, how our head is moving over time,
and how our expressions change. That is an
absolutely outrageous idea, except the fact that
it works. It not only works, but it works really
well. And because this is an amazing paper,
it does not stop there - it can do even more.
Look at these two previous methods
trying to frontalize the input video.
This means that we look to the side a little,
and the algorithm synthesizes a new image of
us as if the camera was right in front of us.
That sounds like a science fiction movie, except
that it seems absolutely impossible given how
much these techniques are struggling with the
task…until we look at the new method. My goodness.
There is some jumpiness in the neck movement
in the output video here, and some warping issues
here, but otherwise, very impressive results.
Now if you have been holding on to your papers
so far, now, squeeze that paper, because these
previous methods are not some ancient papers
that were published a long time ago. Not at
all! Both of them were published within the same
year as the new paper. How amazing is that. Wow.
And it could also perform these deepfakes too.
Look! We only need one image of the target person,
and we can transfer all of our gestures to
them, in a way that is significantly better
than most previous methods. Now, of course,
not even this technique was perfect,
it still struggled a great deal in the presence
of occluder objects, but still, just the fact
that this is now possible feels like we are
living in the future. What a time to be alive!
Now, I said that today we are going to
see that this paper is as real as it gets,
so, what does that mean? Well, today,
anyone can try this technique. Yes, just
one year after publishing this paper,
and it is now available as a demo. The link to
it is available in the video description below.
And, get this, some people at NVIDIA are already
using it for their virtual meetings. And by “it”,
I mean both the compression engine, where
the previous industry standard compression
algorithm could do this when given very little
data. That is not much. But the new technique,
with the same amount of data, can now
do this. That is insanity. Loving it.
And, they also use their own gestures to create
these deepfakes and make virtual characters
come alive, or to frontalize their videos when
talking to each other. It almost feels like we
are living in a science fiction movie.
And all this is out there for us to use.
Also, these technologies will soon
be part of the NVIDIA Video Codec SDK
as the AI Face Codec, which means that it will be
soon deployed to an even wider audience to use.
These companies are already using it. So,
this is one more amazing example that shows
that the papers that you see here in Two Minute
Papers are real. Sometimes so real that we can go
from a research paper to a product in just
a year. That is absolutely miraculous.
So, what do you think? What would you use
this for? Let me know in the comments below!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!